human immunodeficiency virus is the
disease that causes AIDS 78 million
people in the world are currently
affected by HIV it is treatable but not
curable the recent and fast-paced
technology in the medical field has made
it easier to identify HIV and start
treating it since its discovery in 1983
once the virus enters your body it
starts to attack your immune cells they
are built to fight off infections if HIV
progresses to the point where it
destroys all of the T cells in your body
then the infection gets to the final
stage and converts to AIDS the search
for a vaccine has risen in the
discussions that scientists and doctors
are having currently the protein ccr5 is
located at on the surface of your immune
cells a few individuals in the world are
born with a genetic mutation called
Delta 32 our vaccine will introduces
mutation into the immune system as
prevention for HIV the advances in
technology that we have who get us to
the point where we can find the vaccine
and a cure for HIV
I
you